>> OUR 2020 ROUNDUP.
THE ATTACK AGAINST KAMALA HARRIS
HAD EVERYONE TALKING IN THE LAST
DEBATE.
>> SENATOR HARRIS IS PROUD OF
HER RECORD AS A PROSECUTOR AND
WILL BE A PROSECUTOR IN THE
PRESENT.
I AM CONCERNED ABOUT THIS
RECORD.
SHE PULLED OVER 1500 PEOPLE IN
JAIL FOR MARIJUANA VIOLATIONS.
>> AND HARRIS'S SUPPORT AMONG
BLACK DEMOCRATS IS PLUMMETING
AFTER THAT FACE OFF.
THE CANDIDATE DROPPED TO JUST 1%
AMONG THE CRUCIAL VOTING BLOCK
BEHIND BIDEN, SANDERS AND
WARREN.
DONNA, CAN SHE RECOVER FROM THIS
IF SHE DOES A DECENT JOB
PREPARING FOR THE NEXT DEBATE?
>> SHE PUT A LOT OF PEOPLE
BEHIND BARS.
THAT'S THE ROLE OF A PROSECUTOR.
AT A TIME WHEN THE COUNTRY WAS
FOCUSSED ON POLICE BRUTALITY AND
WHAT HAPPENED WITH MICHAEL BROWN
IN FERGUSON, MISSOURI, SOME
PEOPLE FELT SHE DOES NOT DO
ENOUGH.
I BELIEVE SHE HAS A GREAT RECORD
ON CRIME.
UNFORTUNATELY IN A DEBATE YOU
GET 30 SECONDS TO RESPOND, YOU
CAN'T DEFEND YOURSELF.
>> AND SHE PROSECUTED 25 PARENTS
FOR TRUANCY.
>> I INTERVIEWED HER IN 2009.
SHE HAD A REALLY GOOD POINT
ABOUT THE FACT THAT KID HAVE TO
BE SOME SCHOOL.
IF YOU DON'T GET THEM IN SCHOOL
THEY WON'T HAVE A GOOD FUTURE.
SHE IS GOING OUT WITH HER FIRST
TV AD IN IOWA.
I DON'T KNOW IF IT WILL HAVE AN
IMPACT.
SHE IS TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
ANOTHER WAY TO COMMUNICATE
WITHOUT RELYING ON THE 15 SECOND
REPLAY.
>> IN DOESN'T FLY IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
>> I DON'T KNOW IN THAT ATTACK
MATTERED TO A LOT OF PEOPLE.
WHAT I LIKE ABOUT HER, SHE
REMIND ME OF ME AT A RESTAURANT
LISTENING TO THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
WHEN THERE IS A REALLY LONG LIST
OF SPECIAL COUNSEL.
-- SPECIAL COUNSEL.
SHE JUST LOOKS ANNOYED.
I LIKE THE WAY SHE LOOKS.
SHE JUST HAD IT.
SHE GETS THAT LOOK IN HER EYE:
ARE YOU SERIOUS?
>> HAND ON THE HIP.
>> I HATE WHEN THEY READ THE
SPECIALS AND THEY KNOW YOU WON'T
ORDER FROM THE SPECIALS AND THEY
HAVE TO DO IT.
EVERYONE IS BORED.
THEY JUST HAVE TO MEMORIZE IT.
THE SELECTIONS ARE NOT THAT GOOD
ANYWAY.
THEN YOU HAVE TO READ TO SEE
WHAT IS IN IT AND YOU ARE DRUNK.
IT HAS 20 THINGS.
>> GO BACK TO THE 3rd ONE.
>> THE ONE WITH THE CHICKEN.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> YOUR MIND WANDERED WHEN WE
WERE TALKING BECAUSE YOU ARE
HUNGRY.
>> I AM STARVING.
I THINK HE  SHE IS A ONE HIT
WONDER AGAINST JOE AND NOW
FLATTENED OUT.
>>>> I THINK SHE JUST HAD A BAD
NIGHT AND WILL COME BACK.
FRUSTRATIONS ABOUT THE
DEMOCRATICT DEBATES SAYING IT'S
DEMEANING.
>> YOU ARE NOT CALL THEM
DEBATES.
WHAT THEY ARE IS A REALITY TV
SHOW AND YOU HAVE TO COME UP
WITH A SOUND BITE.
IT'S DEMEANING TO THE CANDIDATES
AND IT'S DEMEANING TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> I CAN EXPLAIN HIS HEALTHCARE
PLAN IN 24 SECOND.
THEY ARE TAKING AWAY YOUR
HEALTHCARE AND WILL DOUBLE YOUR
TAXES.
>> HE IS SAYING IT'S FLAWED BUT
IT'S NOT UNFAIRED BECAUSE IT'S
APPLIED EQUALLY TO ALL
CANDIDATES WHICH IS SOCIALISM.
HE SHOULD EMBRACE IT.
>> I LIKE BERNIE SANDERS POD
CAST VOICE.
>> YES!
>> I HAVE NEVER HEARD THAT
BEFORE.
USUALLY HE'S YELLING AND
SCREAMING.
>> IT'S SOOTHEING.
>> YES, IT DREW ME IN.
>> HE IS COMPLAINING ABOUT
SOMETHING HE HELPED ACHIEVE.
THE DNC SAID WE WILL ALLOW MORE
PEOPLE TO BE ON THE DEBATE STAGE
OR BERNIE SANDERS CAN HAVE HIS
COMPLAINTS FROM THE LAST TIME
AROUND TAKEN CARE OF.
IS CNN SUPPOSED TO HAVE A 10
HOUR DEBATE?
>> BERNIE SANDERS COMPLAINS A
LOT.
>> YES.
>> I SHOULD NOT TALK ABOUT CNN.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> I LOVE IT.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> LORD HAVE MERCY!
>> WE HAVE MUST SEE TV.
NEW YORK CITY MAYOR BILL DE
BLASIO IS SITTING DOWN WITH SEAN
HANNITY TONIGHT.
>> HE IS A GOOD INTERVIEWER.
HE WILL GET A SHARE SHOT ON THE
"HANNITY" SHOW.
IF HE COMES AT SEAN HANNITY AND
TRIES TO TACKLE SEAN HANNITY HE
BETTER LOOK OUT.
>> I WANT TO BE THE MODERATOR.
I THINK I AM THE BEST MODERATOR.
I AM FAIR.
>> SO FAIR.
>> I KNOW BOTH OF THEM!
I CAN'T WAIT!
>> DE BLASIO IS THE POSTER BOY
FOR HOW SOCIAL FAILS PEOPLE IN
NEED.
>> HE HAS NOTHING TO LOSE
BECAUSE HE IS AT 1%.
THAT'S THE ONLY REASON HE IS
DOING THIS.
DUCKED SEAN WHEN HE WAS RUNNING
NEW YORK INTO THE GROUND.
NOW HE NEEDS A LITTLE EXTRA.
>> HE WILL GET AN EXTRA BOP.
>> NOT AMONG OUR VIEWERS.
>> HE HAS TO COME INTO NEW YORK
CITY.
YOU KNOW HOW TERRIBLE THAT IS.
>> WITH THE TRAFFIC.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> HE MIGHT GET LOST.
>> I CAN'T STAND THIS GUY, BUT I
GIVE HIM HIS PROPS FOR COMING
AND DOING THIS.